I think I'm a seven or an 8
. okay
patchy what do you give yourself one to
ten honestly bro I give myself a four
four
yeah if you had asked me would I give
myself when I had that cycling picture
I'd be like dog I ate but you know what
do you give yourself man now that you're
bald talk to us bro honestly I'd say
like a seven and a half eight what
actually you know what I'm not gonna lie
like I was trying to be like nice but
I'm a ton yeah I'm a 10. yeah I'm a 10.
no but I don't know like I've worked
really hard and you know I mean I'm tall
I'm intelligent I have money Define
intelligent uh I like cars I hate Tate
nah I'm proud of you man proud of you
you definitely built up something that
in a very short span that a lot of
people can't even do in years you know
you know what's nice is like a lot of
the people that when I when I shave my
head they're like oh you're not going to
get any more girls and I was pulling
girls just fine we were out in Miami
Bros I was talking to women all the time
were like no problem like don't even
think about the hair bro like at the end
of the day the hair is not the person
inside you it's literally just hair so
keep you warm indeed but bro my my
[__] head got so sunburned oh my God
that's something I didn't expect yeah
well hey man it's um it's definitely a
whole different thing like I said I'm
from the Caribbean bro so I got that
Caribbean genetic I'm like anti-suburned
I'm a 10 and every girl here is a 10.
okay well we'll let the girls go but
okay let them speak for themselves well
yeah thank you
I think I'm a nine yeah
okay
five
seven eight
he says everyone so I guess we gotta
rate ourselves John do you wanna I give
myself a seven all right I get myself
like six 6.9 on a good day you know but
uh so
okay you gave yourself a 10. yeah
yeah and you said every girl here should
also think that they're a 10. yeah
because yes I'm bald room full of very
beautiful woman right now and I think we
should all think that we're beautiful
and I don't think we should rate
ourselves like look who's asking us to
rate ourselves
the boys on the chat boys are in the
chat well I'll have you know Stiffler
that bro what the [__] whoever that guy
is he uh
he's he's a handsome guy Stephen
Stiffler the stiff Meister
don't know who that is you don't know
the stiff Meister
I think we should grade ourselves like I
don't know I feel like
just say you're a ton you're all
beautiful no you're not have you ever
played that game he's a 10 but
he wears flip-flops have you ever played
that game yeah I guess oh oh okay so
yeah that's interesting so okay
um
you think we shouldn't you shouldn't
rate yourselves
well
I don't
have to rate yourself
she has an opinion on everything I just
I don't know you guys are just kind of
like asking you because I decided to say
I'm a 10 and every girl here is a 10 do
you guys not think every girl here is no
certainly not no okay then that's your
opinion but from my eyes I want you to
rate every girl there from one to done
start off with the girl with the
brunette white top all right this chick
I'd give her a solid eight she's good
looking keep going six six five
six five okay
my turn yeah I can agree with you on the
first row eight
second girl would you give her a six
yeah yeah I think a six is fair third
from a [__] instant zero if I heard
that bitch's voice
um the fourth girl she's all right but
she's like afforded me this guy right
here is definitely a four and this last
goes like a three
they're asking what are you eating the
[__] base mom made yeah we're eating
the most incredible meal sponsored by
your base the mother
right here every girl here is beautiful
right so your opinion must be more than
ours got it
I'm not saying your opinion I think all
the girls here are attractive but like
if if you're asking me to be honest and
I wouldn't I would never rate you
individually but like
okay we got those last two girls to rig
what do you rate her the redhead ish
girl what are you Raider [__] listen
to
it's like [__] yeah and then the last
girl I I can honestly give her like a
seven eight like I think she's actually
attractive yeah she's pretty this one's
all right not really my type you know
yeah I don't know
what are you gonna do I'm gonna be
honest please don't take this the wrong
way and I don't think I'm a 10. I gave
myself six six point nine there's no
tens at the table yep
I think you're wrong I think from your
eyes yeah the from what I think well
she's actually really okay so look
there's so do you think it's like a
confidence thing or you just you should
be confident in yourself yes because I
mean there's a difference between
confidence and thinking that you're on
par with the most beautiful women in the
world who are supermodels and on the
front of magazine meatballs 10 out of
ten girls and because I'm not on a
magazine cover it's a truth you could be
you could be a 10 and not be
a model however
you are if you're a 10 you are as
attractive as women who are the most
beautiful women in the world who are
mammals you know I know for a fact that
girl doesn't think everybody in the
panel is a 10. I think that's absolute
[__] women have this mentality where
they like to cling around ugly girls per
se no offense to anybody I'm the ugly
friend
and that's how they build their esteem
up dude so I know for a fact she doesn't
think everybody there's a ton there's no
way all those women on that panel could
be a 10. I mean dude not to be a dick
but I got bigger tits than all those
girls dude except the girl the white top
that's kind of [__] too though you
know I shouldn't be like that's a weird
brag for sure it is a weird bribe but
it's just trying to say like you know
that's not 10 bodies dude yeah
not brother it's hard to say dude I'm
not trying to sound like an [__] but
you know it's just not no I feel you on
my time look at me I'm a cat fart into
the mic don't you think it's a bit of uh
hubris why do you want me to rate myself
lower
well I mean you're free to I suppose
you're free I'm going to though
I'm not planning on forcing you to I
know but it kind of like by the way that
you're talking to me it kind of seems
like a weird it kind of seems like
you're telling me I'm not a 10 which is
fine that's your own opinion but you
asked me to rate myself and I'm being
honest I think I'm a 10. if well okay if
I said I was a 10 that would put me on
par with Brad Pitt when he was young
with Leonardo when he was young I don't
know if Leo was a 10 in this Prime was
Leo 10 in this Prime I don't know he was
a babe
um it's just what are you gonna do to
lose this weight everyone's asking
what's your plan no they're not they're
no they're not where are they were they
asking I've seen it what's what's the
plan
you know every a goal doesn't mean
anything without a plan yeah what are
you gonna do definitely stop coming to
your mother's house because if I do I'm
gonna have to eat meatballs all the time
and I'm gonna get the meatballs is an
exception
this is a home this is a home-cooked
meal the meatballs are protein
it's protein it's a little bit of pasta
like this isn't like the most unhealthy
[__] in the world no no not at all um so
as far as me losing weight I think the
first thing that I have to you know
definitely acknowledge is diet and diet
I definitely need to come up with income
so I'm gonna actually create an income a
source of income so I can afford quality
food
um I think people understand the fact
that you know I eat a lot of fast food a
lot and consistently so it puts on I
also drink a lot of soda so I'm going to
be cutting that out first of all and I
was gonna start going to the gym and
just like not overdo it I'm gonna kind
of wind myself into it so I can kind of
create a routine per se but yeah man
just simply go to the gym eat better and
and pay attention to what goes into my
mouth
[Music]
enough
for a brother riding on the wall won't
last long yeah the feelings
[Music]